Larson Pittman and Michael Jordan's son
Marcus pack on the PDA people say you're
dating
I have a lot of friends I mean I'm very
social I was married for 23 years like
this is the time for me to really like
hone in on my relationships so that's
kind of what I'm doing scenes with two's
latest display seemingly confirms Sparks
are flying amid dating rumors yeah
that's Larsa kissing Marcus outside of a
Miami Hotel over the weekend I feel like
I'm in a new place new energy you know
New Beginnings I'm excited about the
journey and where my life is going
Larsa and Marcus first began fueling
dating Rumors in September A source told
ET at the time they're casually hanging
out quote Larsa and Marcus have a lot of
the same friends in common so they've
been around one another a lot and enjoy
hanging out they are having fun together
I feel like my type is a bit different
than the other girls types yeah yeah
yeah you you told me you're like a boss
I like a boss but I like a I like a
really like I like a sweetheart I like a
boss but like someone that's really
sweet and like caring too okay so you
you almost you're like a hard shell
candy like hard on the outside soft on
the inside
yes yes there we go that's that's what I
love now Larsa and Marcus do have a
connection through her ex-husband
Scottie Pippen my husband Scotty is a
retired NBA player he's only won like
six championships All-Star team like
seven times so he's a pretty good
basketball player yep Marcus just so
happens to be the son of Scotty's
Chicago Bulls teammate Michael Jordan
watching you and Michael on the court it
looked like two best friends out there
just crushing everybody what was your
relationship like off the court
it wasn't what you saw on the court we
always will have that respect uh for
each other but our friendship is not
where people see it on TV think it Is
Well when things aren't heating up
between Larsa and Marcus she's busy
bringing the heat to season five of The
Real Housewives of Miami
no it's not called fighting dirty with
stocks we're trying to hurt me
more that's a fact I feel like if you
say something bad about me I'm just
naturally going to say something twice
as bad about you like that's just my
personality I just feel like a lot of
people don't understand who I really am
and so I feel like a lot of people like
you know hate on me a little bit because
they don't understand like who I am
where I come from and so for me I just
feel like as long as I stay in my lane
and I work hard and I focus on the
things that matter to me then that's all
that matters the haters will always be
there and as far as if we'll see Marcus
on the reality show Lars is still
playing Coy about that will we see you
date on the new season
I did a little bit on the new season
yeah
[Music]